ah all right looks like we're good still
gonna need this I just get together wait
yeah man hey think we need to add to
this episode our turn to Jessica Jones
by the time this show is done man this
was uh
whoof is intense uh I was a little kid
this we give me nightmare yeah why good
good good job we're always talking about
how things aren't dark enough like it
were back when we were kids that is show
what I mean that was like I love dr.
Moreau type shit going down there things
can get dark but a lot of times they
feel like they're dark for no reason
this definitely feels like it has a
reason it is this feel justified yeah
this feels do it wasn't even like drawn
that dark it just the subject matter was
dark when the way was presented and the
way it was I mean even when she starts
to split apart there I mean that's it's
got some disturbing animation there I
mean I met your little kid you see one
of your heroes just like her back is
splitting up and her eyes open up and
she's crying as all these hands are
trying to grab me that one in review is
it edited so beautifully and the music
with the two different sides of her
talking ah no this can't be oh they're
here all along oh this is punishment for
the rebellion is this what I was going
to happen I'm like sure you know what I
like too as soon as they say you know I
bet Ruby and Sapphire can help us fold
I'm like well okay we're obviously go
see Ruby at sapphire and we didn't yeah
and this is one of the few times where
it's like I always thinks are the the
ten minutes that they have for each
episode are really time really good a
lot like adventure time they they know
how to utilize the time this was the one
time I'm like God I wish there was more
I mean it's anybody a good way like you
know yeah I always leave I'd rather
leave wanting more than ya could have
any it's like you know never separate
the pair on and they pull them together
it's like you know okay okay good but
turns it with the help really wanted
more um I mean that this is an episode
peridot comes back or at least they find
her we don't know well don't we do know
what she was doing apparently she was
combining the shards of destroyed gems
which is pretty much like dead people uh
I
putting them together creating these
just these hands and feet and arms and
does nightmarish yeah it really was
no it what a testament to how well you
know it's a different type of world
building because we've just been getting
pieces at a time but shards if you will
what a testament to how well the show
has basically gone about the world
building and telling us what's important
and why these things are important and
how this universe works that when she
said oh these are the old gems ease of
the shards they've been buried and
they've been reap it back together that
I'm just like unholy abomination in his
own jar you shittim Utley hits you where
I think if you started off with this you
know and said oh the gems are kind of
like people and these are shards and now
they're put Davy oh we're by John you
come to a point where it's like yeah
whoa like that's really messed up like
my daddy it sinks in I got it I'm like
this I'm like this is fucked up fucked
up um so yeah I I you know I also like
that this was a very pedal up with
Steven and pearl done started
oh no we have had a lot no you have had
a lot with Steven listen stop drinking
this is I like that this is episode I
like that this is very uh Steven and a
garnet toasty toasty it's vicious logic
um yeah I like that this is about them
kind of bonding and and Steven seeing
you know shit go down with garnet and is
worried about their eye I just like the
way the two interacted i Steven only
says moments with all three and I like
that so this is definitely a Steven
garnet episode whereas the other when we
had Steven pearl and they each have a
different dynamic so then that I don't
feel like these three characters are all
the same and therefore you get a bonding
episode you're just going to see the
same thing just with a different
character so um one this is one of the
reasons I love you know this is why I
loved x-men growing up I really like
group environments because you're
allowed
Batman is awesome and Superman is
awesome I love those characters but
there's something about when you put
them in a group and you can just see the
interaction off each other
you'll Bugs Bunny is great but you put
Bugs Bunny with Daffy Duck and Elmer
Fudd and these other character you see
how they work off each are ants the same
thing here I love when pearl and
amethyst go chase after peridot so you
know they're still contributing they're
a part of the team but yeah we monitor
who fingers for tea but garnet and
Steven are gonna go do their own thing
too and they're gonna have some an
interesting connection I think with
group environments you're constantly
finding new connections and new stories
and new relationships you can constantly
build and grow well again it's all about
the metaphors for love marriage identity
yeah gender identity and an identity of
any sort on that I mean that's what's so
great you don't have to be going through
like you know you don't have to have
like be going through a gender identity
crisis you'll have to be going through
you don't have to be in a marriage with
someone you don't to be in anything like
that it's just it's all it's subjective
in just the right way um I mean I think
we can both say we really I really
connected with a scene at the end where
she's talking about what it's like to be
fused and especially I always call my
wife I always say it's like it's I just
feel like even though I've only known
her for like eight years it's like she
feel like she's my right arm it just
feels like that like I've always known
this person so yeah I did that's why I
really like the idea of fusion it's like
and to remind myself that it's a kid
show because I thought initially when
they were talking about it earlier in
the episode where it's like well it's
two parts become greater than the whole
or whatever she was basically saying I
mean I am I was like well what a
wonderful metaphor for marriage or um
love um yes you can those two can be the
same doesn't have a lot of this funnel
bump
and I was gonna say this I'm asleep on
the cab um that's opposed to a well plan
but um yeah and the thing is I got it I
didn't need any more explanation I got
everything about what it's like to be
fusion from that one little speech and
then kinda keeps talking at the end of
the part of me is just like I need this
I already got my mic that's right I'm a
grown-ass adult wasn't encouraged like
it you know it's like I get it cuz I'm
an adult but it you know it spell it out
for the kids just in case well I make
the argument I was a well it was a
well-written speech yeah it was funny
though cuz I'm just like I keep
forgetting I'm like hey this meant for
like kids like so something that's
subtle that I'm like no that was fine
the way was it was subtle sometimes need
to spell out a little more but II would
I thought it was a great ending well I
would even make the argument I like even
not for kids because I mean it's
definitely for kids but there are people
I need all of us we've all seen people
whose emotional development go slower uh
you know or they don't always catch on
to certain social cues and stuff and I
think shows like this again I think this
is why my laponia so popular is because
it is talking about that social
interaction as talking about in a very
slow fair way that anyone can understand
that's why anyone grasped onto it I
think it was aimed at kids first is
there any actually as obviously this is
up but I'm saying that's why I'm running
beyond a prime time on NBC or something
like it it's aimed first and if Rebecca
sugar wants to aim at a larger crowd
that's fine but I it's still I think no
it's a kid show first yeah it's a silly
jokes instead but facility so good and
everything you can't be too subtle um
which is what I think happened and I'm
fun that I excite exceed out it was a
great speech I like to there's a good
moral in there about you can't force
people to be something they're not which
is what the other gems are dot or
whatever they're doing it's like you
know fusion that was like garnets choice
those two coming together and what's
going on here it's like forcing some
it's like praying away the gay or
somebody is like you you can't force
somebody to be something they're not
you can't take these two things that
aren't
so yeah I can't afford speed out
together you can't force people apart
like it just it's fucking it something
deal with it universe um I'll deep in
universe I also like you know the two
things that uh it's funny because you
know this is mostly a garnet episode I
you know I just even say a to is Stevens
comedic moments in this I thought were
really legitimately funny well first of
all the way if you watch the way he
falls close he they really animated him
like he folds it like a little kids are
putting the head down and doing that and
stuff I hadn't even noticed love the way
they an amazing even as a real little
kid uh and the way they talked and
everything is so genuine so so a little
kid a scene though where she asks are
the others yes and that's the air seems
got to point out what it ray this
moment's just making sure so and then
yeah so well animated and you don't need
that scene you could have cut that you
didn't even really need to have Stephen
come across diva it does it doesn't add
anything like crucial to the story but
it's just such a funny moment and no
yeah and it's just a funny one it's also
good apology story yeah I might say
something like you see in a coma
brothers movie where it's like the
Selassie and say you don't need that but
it just adds so much character in so
much comedy and so much awkwardness to
you know a show that has so many bad as
scenes and somebody thinks are well and
out that's great to have something it
just makes them feel more human little
touches like that make a show yeah so
it's the attention to detail when I
watch a really good anime or really good
animated film it's the little things
that you didn't need to do you wasted
paper or program or megabytes or
whatever if it's a CGI movie you wasted
time money and effort doing that and yet
those little moments make it like you
didn't need it you wasted the time doing
it in the film or the show is actually
better for it
you know I remember when uh slightly on
top and I first saw Coraline and I knew
I was gonna love this movie when there's
a scene where she enters a room well how
do you animate someone entering a room
turns the knob opens up the door comes
in but you know good animation
away with good characters you see her
hanging on the door that leans her open
and then she lets go and she walks in it
just immediately gives her so much care
yeah so much life and she just feels
alive and I feel like this show and
again the thing I like most visual
storytelling no dialogue
yeah told you things you need to know
about a character without of line uh not
really good episode I did very nicely
done
um yeah definitely definitely nightmare
fuels so um sweet dreams
oh I'm not gonna be able to unsee that
don't worry the couch is very comfy